- You need to bet on your strengths.
- Knowing your strengths.
- Show them their strengths.
- You need to know what
your unique strengths are.
- Work on the strength.
- Cultivate my strengths.
- Recognize your own strengths.
- Knows how to play to their strengths.
- Your strengths.
- Strengths.
- Hello, Believe Nation.
Today we're going to look at how
you can bet on your strengths.
And as always, guys, if you hear something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired,
and when you write it down yourself,
it's much more likely to
stick with you, as well.
Enjoy.
(fast orchestral music)
- You need to bet on your strengths
and don't give a, about what you suck at.
Way too many people in this
room are going to spend
the next 30, 40 years of their lives
trying to check the boxes of the things
that they're not as good at and that
you're going to waste a
load of time and lose.
I highly recommend auditing yourself.
Or if you have no empathy
or EQ or self-awareness,
then find somebody in your
family or friendship that does
and let them tell you who you are.
And once you believe that,
either for yourself or
someone else told you,
go directly all chips all into that.
Because that is the only
possible way in my opinion
watching from the outside
that is, let me rephrase,
that is a very highly,
likely way of over-indexing.
Because the truth is if
you want to be an anomaly,
you've got to act like one.
And so, that's it, that's what I got.
So, thanks for having me.
- I think the most important is
knowing your strengths and weaknesses,
and knowing what you enjoy doing.
If you look at it as a
job, you've already lost.
It's not going to be your passion
and you're going to count the hours.
If you look at it as
something you love to do,
and then you know what your strengths are,
then you can leverage those strengths
in your business and in helping others.
And once you recognize your weaknesses,
then you can work with
people that complement you.
I mean, every one of my businesses
I've had a partner who's
very anal (laughing).
Martin Woodall, Todd Wagner, I mean,
incredibly anal people,
perfectionists, because I'm a slob.
I'm a big picture, think
about what's round the corner,
how's technology going to change things,
how can I change this industry,
and making sure that
there's somebody there
to dot the i's, cross the t's
and keep me in the baselines.
Recognizing my weaknesses
is just as important as
recognizing my strengths,
my core competencies,
and having a passion to do them.
- So when you meet new
talent, emerging talent,
and you're mentoring them,
what if you don't have
the confidence that they have,
the level of talent required
to achieve greatness,
how do you counsel them?
What do you say to make
them feel confident,
to not rob them of that moment,
but also steer them in
the right direction?
I mean, you can't say,
you really, mmm nnn, you're a zero.
- By talking to them, understanding
what their concerns are,
what sort of self image they have,
and trying to show them
their strengths, too.
And if they have some kind of weakness,
we'll try to not focus
on those weaknesses.
I think in entertainment
industry that's what works.
You know your strengths, you milk them.
You know your weaknesses,
you try not to focus on them so much
so that the audience doesn't
focus on them as much.
- You need to know what
your unique strengths are
and be willing to delegate.
So I would say that the question
of whether you should take a skill,
learn it yourself, delegate
it to someone else,
or hire a new member are determined
by having a very accurate self-assessment,
and assessment of your team's skills.
Not only what you can do but
what you should be doing.
That's very important.
So if you're a start-up CEO or founder,
and you have a team of
say two to 10 people,
as soon as you have funds to hire,
you should not be focused on
the things that you are bad at.
Sounds very intuitive but it's not.
Because you might have enough
time to do those things,
but the question is do
you have the attention
to dedicate to those things so
they're not an interruption.
Especially if you're a
venture-backed start-up
and you're competing
against other companies
that also have a lot of funding,
the game in the race goes to the swift,
so you have to have a lot of velocity.
- Remember where your roots are,
and remember where your strengths lie
I think is especially
also important for me.
I always believe these are my strengths
and this is what either
in tennis I work on,
or these are my strengths
in my personality,
and this is what also maybe what
people want to see and hear and feel.
I think many people always feel like
they have to work on their weaknesses.
I don't know how it works in
the business world as much,
but anyway in tennis
working on your weaknesses
makes maybe an overall complete player,
but you won't be dangerous anymore.
So I think you can
sometimes relate to that
in some businesses, as well.
That's why I like to work on the strength
and it's really helped
me throughout my career.
- The thing that you're
most comfortable with
that you do the best,
because that's what you're
going to do the best.
Like me, I've got strengths
and I've got weaknesses.
I don't work on my weaknesses.
I ignore them and I
cultivate my strengths.
The level of achievement
that we have at anything
is a reflection of how well
we were able to focus on it.
Because the only thing
that's holding you back
is the way you're thinking.
- It's very important, and
I also come back to chess,
to learn how to recognize your
own strengths and weaknesses.
This is, in fact, the vital part
of preparation for a big match.
And for anything in life.
We always try to study our points.
We always try to study the backend field.
We always try to study
all the circumstances
surrounding our venture, endeavor.
But very often we forget to study ourself.
And this is very important,
because any choice of a ground for battle,
or type of strategy one can employ,
depends on our recognition of
our strengths and weaknesses.
And this is a process of
constant reevaluation.
Because life is changing very fast.
And our points, looking at our success,
studying it and trying to be smart
and out-smart us eventually.
And we can look at the history
just to find a number of situations
where the inability to recognize
strengths and weaknesses
led to an eventual disaster.
- A girl boss is someone who, I guess,
takes charge of her own life.
So if it's a girl boss or a buy boss.
it's someone who know their weaknesses
and knows what their strengths are,
and knows how to play to their strengths.
I think there's a lot of people out there,
and I've interviewed a lot of them who,
my favorite interview question is,
name your biggest strength
and your biggest weakness,
or what do you have to work on.
The scariest people are
the ones who say like,
I show up early, it's my biggest weakness.
Or like, I work too much,
it's my biggest weakness.
Everybody has things that
they can improve upon.
And I think a world where everybody's
more aware of that is a good one
and a place where people can be empowered
to make choices in their life,
rather than throw themselves into places
that they may not inherently be successful
because the world has sold them some story
of what they should be doing.
So I guess a girl boss is
someone who is in choice.
- You must begin life,
and you must approach life
with your strengths,
It's absolutely essential.
Everyone in schooling very
often keeps on pushing one
to focus on what is wrong with us
or tells us what is wrong with us.
And there is a very
interesting imaginary story
of a rabbit, and you must hear this one.
The rabbit was enrolled
in the rabbit school.
And like all rabbits, it could
hop very well but could not swim.
At the end of the year
the rabbit got high marks
in hopping but failed in swimming.
The parents were concerned.
The relations were concerned.
The friends were concerned,
the elder friends particularly.
They said, "Forget about hopping,
you're anyway good at it,
"you don't have to keep practicing it,
"concentrate on your swimming."
And then they sent the rabbit
for tuitions and coaching in swimming.
And guess what happened?
The rabbit forgot how to hop.
As for swimming, have you
ever seen a rabbit swim?
While it is important for us to know
what we are not good at,
we must cherish what is good enough.
It's very fundamental to life.
That is because it is
only on our strengths
that can give us the energy
to correct our weaknesses.
- I think it's one of our strength.
There are strength of
being a big car corporation
with all the resources you have at hand.
But there are also strengths for a small
founder-driven sports car company
that we have to utilize to
compensate for the lack of size.
- Thank you, guys, so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what
was your favorite clip,
what resonated the most with you,
what are you going to
take from this video,
and immediately apply to your
life or your business somehow.
Please leave it down in the comments,
I'm super curious to find out.
Thank you, guys, again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.